[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host it's
common sense for your dollars and cents
here on the ramsey show we're glad
you're with us america thank you for
joining us open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five starting this hour off sacramento
california scott's with us hey scott how
are you
good how are you better than i deserve
man what's up
all right so i'm a teacher and the way
the pay works is that
the more post bachelor degree units that
you have the higher your pay is so when
you reach
a certain threshold you'll move over on
the pay scale to the right and the
further over to the right the more money
you make so i'm trying to figure out if
it makes sense to pursue
a master's degree to get more
post-bachelor degree units or if i
should do professional development
seminars
which can give you units but
i'm not sure if it's worth doing 97
professional development seminars
and paying for those units that route
well uh
you can look at it several different
ways one way you would look at it and it
sounds like the way you're asking the
question is simply this
what does it cost
to increase
the boxes that you can check to the
right
and then how much money do you get
increased income due to that cost so
it's the cost versus the benefit
analysis right
so you spend a thousand dollars on
either of these
whether it's pursuing the masters or the
professional development and uh your
income goes up x right so is it worth it
yeah it needs to go up you know and you
get it every year with the income you
only spend the thousand dollars once
uh on in either case so that's good the
other thing that you can add to that is
a collection of personal development
seminars
really just gives you that collection
you do get all the knowledge from them
if however you did a collection that led
to a master's degree you do come out of
that with a master's degree which is a
nice extra benefit to have that so
i'm probably going that route if the
costs are similar
okay yeah and from what i can gather the
cost for the masters
is
anywhere from three to five x of what it
takes to do
the professional development and the
professional development it might be a
three-day seminar so the commitment is
far less yeah but what's the return
right so and it seems to me that it
costs maybe a hundred to two hundred
dollars per unit
uh if you will on the professional
development where it costs around
someone that can gather about 500
dollars per unit if you're doing a
master's program okay and then how much
do they pay you increase your pay for a
unit
so
it's in increments of 15 units so if i
did the masters they would bump me over
two whole columns and that would be
about a five thousand dollar per year
pay increase
okay and the master's degree would cost
what
about fifteen thousand
okay so in three years you break even
and the personal development would cost
you uh it sounds like about five
thousand
right for the same amount of
column movement
did i do that right
yes that's correct okay so one's three
times more than the other both of them
increase you about so you can spend five
thousand can you do both
doesn't do any good because there's only
so many columns
yeah
right there there's
five columns i think yeah if you do both
it doesn't yeah if you did both it
doesn't keep moving you along it so you
wouldn't get a return
right you could you could you max out at
a certain number of units and then it's
just yeah you can't go any further over
okay well just purely on the dollars you
would do the professional development
right
five thousand gets you fifteen thousand
or uh uh i mean five thousand gets you
five thousand a year or fifteen thousand
gets you five thousand a year right did
i do that right yes
uh-huh yeah now this but so you know
you're paying 10 grand for the privilege
of having a master's
that get that that does not increase
your income
if i if i'm understanding your scenario
right that's now there's a of course the
value then is do you want to have a
master's and you know do you want to
spend an extra ten thousand dollars in
order to have that because that might
have uses other times in your life
to have that under your belt versus 67
professional development
uh one other question uh that's a little
bit uh
when you finish
the same number of units of professional
development versus the masters
uh have you increased your knowledge
base
more with the masters that gives you
more job satisfaction you're better at
your job when you go to the masters or
is it about the same or are the
professional development actually better
because they're more practical
i'm gonna if i had to guess i'm gonna
say that the professional development
would be a better increase in knowledge
because there are so many different
options whereas a master's you're more
singularly focused
okay
is there any other reason you should do
a master's then because you got better
knowledge and less money spent on the
professional development side i'm just
walking through this with you i don't
know what i'm talking about i'm just
helping you with the critical thinking
path okay
and so the only thing i hear you're
getting for that extra 10 grand is
substandard knowledge
and a master's degree
right yeah it i don't think it gives me
anything other than
the master's degree title unless i
wanted to pivot later in my career but i
don't see myself wanting to stop
teaching i don't want to i don't want to
move into administration that sounds
well if you did choose that you can
always go back and work on the masters
later but in the meantime i'm going to
jump on 5k for 5k and let's get this
professional development stuff under
your belt get the increased knowledge
the increased joy of teaching because
you're better at it and
and you can always go back and do the
masters later and you may have a
different direction with your masters if
you're doing that because you might be
aiming at administration if you chose to
make that that shift in your track
that's just me thinking through it with
you dude i i'm not an expert on
education uh in terms of the your field
or anything like that i'm just looking
at the return on investment and what's
the quality of what i'm buying and i'm
just thinking through it and what that
does is it puts all the mystery of ooh a
master's degree
and it basically tells you
doesn't mean crap that's what it tells
you
um after we get after we cut through all
of it that's what it came down to so
good question that's interesting thanks
for letting me walk through that with
you open phones this hour common sense
is here and common sense is so rare in
america today that's like having a
superpower so we're glad you're with us
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two
five if you've not seen the new
documentary by ramsey networks borrowed
future
you need to download it and watch it
tonight
uh you can rent it at amazon
prime you can rent it at google you can
rent it at um
apple tv
lots of places you can run it borrow
future.com if you want it's like any
other dock it's about three bucks or
four bucks or whatever to rent it for
the night watch it
and it you know it makes you think about
things like this master's degree
discussion it makes you think about this
higher ed discussion i am not against
four-year degrees i'm not against higher
education i am against people spending
200 000
at some famous college in order to get a
job making 38 000
that's straight up stupid
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
hey guys i got interesting news for you
this year
christmas is in december
they don't move it
it's always there you got 45 days ready
set go
ah
yeah right i hear you
i'm always ready for christmas because i
just love christmas i love celebrations
any excuse to have a party any excuse to
be generous i love christmas
christmas was my chance to be off the
charts crazy
generous and no one looks at me like
i've lost my mind well fewer of them
anyway
plenty of people look at me like i've
lost my mind all the time that's part of
my job
every year we celebrate christmas with
our ramsay show listeners with an
awesome tradition our ramsey christmas
cash giveaway this year we're giving
away 500 every week and a grand prize of
5 000 buckaroos
you can enter every day to increase your
chances of winning just text cash to 33
789 cash to 33789
uh we know you got some giving to do
for your christmas show um in honor of
singles day it's singles day
what does that mean it's veterans day my
team is putting everything on sale today
go ahead get your christmas gift
shopping done while our best sellers are
up to 73 off we have gifts for him gifts
for her gifts for kids of all ages
but this is a one-day sale don't wait to
get started this year you can forget
one-time use presents and grab a
lifetime of hope by the ten dollar books
uh that are on sale and that's almost
all of our books are on sale
for ten bucks at ramseysolutions.com
happy veterans day by the way uh we to
honor all of our veterans
around
they're serving and have served rather
thank you
um
because of people like you i get to sit
here and run my mouth for a living
so um and it's actually legal still at
this point because of people like you
so there you go thank you thank you for
your service all of you some of you have
uh
have paid a price with your minds and
your bodies and your relationships and
everything else in order to keep this
country free so thank you we appreciate
you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from blinds.com a great
american company find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer
of custom window coverings sharon and i
have used this company we love them
they're great people you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run all the time you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from dave in
oklahoma i'm 72 and have a net worth of
over 2 million dollars way to go
my wife and i gave our children who
decided to attend college a family
scholarship
they were responsible responsible for
paying whatever the scholarship didn't
cover
to qualify for the scholarship
they had to get good grades and attend
church regularly they all graduated
college using this system my first
grandchild will start college next year
so i offer the same deal to her i got an
email from her father saying she was
furious that i was trying to force her
to attend church which she already does
voluntarily and that she might quit
attending church over it
other family members think i should have
given her the money with no strings
attached
was it inappropriate for me to have some
provisions around the scholarship that
require grades and religious attendance
i think your granddaughter is a freaking
brat
she's furious because you offered her
free money and she didn't like the terms
call the wambulance
dave this is your money
you could have asked her to stand on her
head for 30 minutes in order to get it
and she has no right to be furious
she can just say i decline your kind
offer because i don't like the terms but
you don't have to be a furious little
brat
so uh
offer withdrawn
and family members that don't like it
can kiss my butt
if they get some money they get to do
with their money what they want to do
with their money but it's your job to
manage this money
and you didn't do anything wrong
you have a solid value system you're a
good man you're kind you didn't do
anything wrong you didn't make a big
deal out of it um
she wasn't worshiping satan and you
tried to get her to quit she was already
attending church well smack me silly oh
my gosh
sounds like she needs to spend some more
time over there to me
oh my goodness
now dude
you know you're
you're just being nicer than i would
have been
i would have just said okay kiddo i'm
going to take you off that list and a
couple of others until you grow up and
decide to be respectful you little twit
so there you go
see i'm kind of old school that way
i just you know
your money you decide
i don't have a right to be offended if
you don't want to put your money on
something i want you to
isn't that weird that's just people are
just so entitled see entitlement is a
form of arrogance
and that's what you're dealing with here
um bless your little heart
which is southern for yeah whatever open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five
two two five todd is with us in denver
colorado hey todd how are you
i'm good how you doing today dave better
than i deserve what's up
fantastic um thanks for taking my call
my wife and i started getting uh very
serious about having no debt probably
about two years ago and that includes
our mortgage
um we're in baby step six right now
uh we have about seven hundred thousand
dollars remaining on our mortgage um and
my question is really about the three to
six months emergency fund
uh we've started does some sinking funds
to kind of cover things like you know
house payments or
house payments sorry house maintenance
or like once a year type payments that
come up you know once a year that are
due good and
and so we got those kind of ready for
that and so we feel like we can cash
flow most kind of emergency things but
we also have this uh capital account at
her
place where she works
and the firm takes a fair amount of
capital
every paycheck and at this point i think
it has about 250 000 in it
and the only way you get that is if you
quit or you're fired and then they pay
that back to you when you quit so the
question i have is
should we or could we keep a smaller
emergency fund since we have these
thinking funds and the capital funds
there just so we can get more intense
with paying the mortgage off faster
sure
yeah i mean your job are your jobs are
both your jobs stable
100 yeah i mean i wouldn't get lo i
wouldn't get lower than three months but
we always say three to six months on the
six-month side if there's more risk in
your house what you're describing is
there's less risk in your house
so three months will be fine if you want
to
um
uh because yeah currently unless you
were to tap into some of those sinking
funds um we we don't have that that
three months emergency but what sounds
crazy at all no i wouldn't know that i
wouldn't do that i'd have three months
i've never met anybody in 30 years of
doing this to say you know i hated
having an emergency fund when stuff came
up
yeah
you know i just i've never met anybody
that did that and so and that little bit
of difference is not going to offset
your 700 000 on this mortgage that much
anyway
so no i would not be below three months
uh but in the three to six month range
you could land on the three comfortably
because you've uh adjusted for risk off
the other side of things now here's the
other thing here's the other thing that
happens that's to your credit to go to
the three-month side is that as you get
into baby steps 456 your
your life when you're broke your life
looks like a country song everything
that can go wrong will
you know murphy shows up every morning
and kicks the tires right and when
you're not broke you have better stuff
and so it doesn't break as much
and you're taking better care of
yourself so you don't break as much
and you know usually that you should
anyway and so what ends up happening is
as you reach a level of wealth and you
start moving through four five six seven
on the baby steps you tend to have fewer
emergencies
you really do
and we always joke and say it's because
the emergency fund is there and the
emergencies are scared but they're not
they're not scared there's just fewer of
them i mean because when you're driving
a piece of crap car it's just more
likely to blow up
than a good car is you know and you move
up you got a little better car right
you're keeping better tires on the car
you're keeping the maintenance up on the
car so it's not going to bust as often
right and when it busts it's not as big
and so you know you tend your your roof
you don't wait till it leaks before you
put a new roof on you know you're doing
normal maintenance because you have a
have a level of prosperity and so your
number of emergencies goes down
as wealth increases
and as you walk along this so that leans
you towards that three-month side too
but i wouldn't go below the three-month
doesn't serve any purpose here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
hey
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage heath is with us hey
heath how are you man i'm doing well how
are you doing better than i deserve
welcome where do you live uh biddeford
maine beniford maine yeah biddeford yeah
what's that near uh portland oh 25 30
minutes from portland yeah i love
portland yeah
been there a bunch of times
love it man well welcome all the way
down to tennessee to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off uh 21
000. all right how long did that take
you 12 months good for you and your
range of income during that time 45 to
60. cool what do you do for a living i
work uh crisis intervention so people
that are struggling with mental health
um you know depression anxiety kind of
busy right now very very busy very busy
yeah it's uh it's been a hard time for
folk out there it's a tough field and
you know people are struggling a lot of
people are struggling and you know um
but you know people need help and that's
what i'm there for yeah i'm glad you're
there very cool good for you
so what kind of debt was this 21 000
yeah i paid off a jeep um i had a fight
yeah i had a family loan that i used to
pay off a high interest credit card
my pepe gave me that and then i paid off
a cell phone
all right yeah okay so just uh kind of
normal pretty normal yeah and you just
looked up how old are you uh 30. i just
i turned 30 in june oh cool so you look
up and you said uh
21 months ago something's got to change
how did you get connected to the ramsey
process yeah great question um i
actually my best friend ben was telling
me about him and his wife doing the dave
ramsey plan and uh pre-covered we went
out to a restaurant you know i told him
all my debt pretty open honest
conversation
and we realized that was pretty much
house poor you know i had some debt had
some bills
i was a hard worker but i you know it's
paycheck to paycheck
um so he gave me your book um he
mentioned your podcast i read the book
great book you know but i i didn't
really start it that right right then
and there
um and then with the pandemic hitting
i'm in maine around march i
i
the podcast saved my life wow i i've
been binge watching the podcast every i
from the first episode to the most
current one and it just opened up my
eyes um and i read your book again and
you know that's how that process started
um
truly the podcast
it was life-saving um you know the calls
that came in
um you know truly opened up my eyes yeah
well it's hard to listen to this stuff
over and over and not eventually go try
it yeah that's the thing like i said oh
no i'm a single guy i can't do it myself
um but i there was calls that came in
and i always i wanted to prove the
haters wrong like you know i wanted to
be like that guy that could do it yeah
um so i listened to your podcast um i
picked up a side gig i did door dash for
a little bit
um but then i actually worked at a covid
shelter um in maine like coveted
positive like new mainers or homeless
homeless people um struggling um with
the kovid um so i worked there opened it
up and i made an extra like 1500 bucks a
month wow i did that for five months it
was tough um i mean it was pretty much
quarantined in my house
um
but it opened up my eyes i wanted to
just do it and get it paid off yeah and
i looked at the debt and i was like i
can't do it but i slowly did it i paid
off you know the smallest to the largest
and it just it just worked wow good for
you man yeah well done well done so who
was cheering you on who are your biggest
cheerleaders well my friend ben and his
lovely wife kendra and they came with
you all the way to tennessee to do the
dead free screen yeah we flew here
didn't drive um yeah so they did i
talked to him every day i called he
called me i called him every morning um
i mean i at first it was difficult
single no one there in the house
but also made it kind of you know easier
because i didn't have to worry about
anyone else spending money you know i
think the hardest part was me eating out
um you know i the budget was i got on
the every dollar app
um you know when i did that two weeks
free of uh financial piece um so that
helped out
um so they helped me i talked to him
every morning my name is justin and
debbie and their two kids they helped me
they he gave me free food i babysit a
little bit we you know we had fires
outside we did a lot of hiking i think
you'll see the pictures on youtube
picture of us hiking
so it was just great and i wanted to
change my
family tree and my legacy um and i think
that's the biggest part of this like i i
grew up in foster care my parents gave
me up when i was four years old
and i got blessed with a great christian
you know foster
family
um you know i didn't hear about you or
anything but i mean i i was raised well
um and when i was 17 i i actually went
back with my my biological parents and
uh for a year and it really
they stole money from me and it was
there it was it was bad
um and i had to go to court and whatnot
and um i got i could go back to my
foster family but i never wanted to
change my last name because i wanted to
ch i wanted to be the first with my last
name to succeed and go to college
and you know
do something right um and you have and i
have what do you know hero thank you way
to go man i'm proud of you very very
cool all right so when people ask you
how does a single guy making 45 to 60
pay off
21 000 in 12 months what do you tell
them the key is to getting out of debt
have a goal
and trust the process and rely on people
if you're struggling yeah you know
you're gonna have bad days you're gonna
you're gonna struggle you know you're
gonna be like i can't do this that's
when you call i called ben i reached out
to my neighbor i called people like i
and some people were like uh you know
you should be investing you should be
doing this but like i listened to the
podcast you know i didn't care what
anyone else was saying
you know it's my life i wanted to change
it right and i want to be debt free
no more stress in the world
and i just wanted to live my life and
how's it feel now that you're there
it it's amazing like i
it's changed my life like you know
and
all my actions have changed and i i'll
never use her credit card i'll never
get a loan like i i'm gonna fault like i
listen to the podcast every single day
and it's just like
it's truly inspiring and i wanna someone
listening right now that's single and
that's drowned in debt or they can't do
it they don't think they can do it you
can do it um and saying that like mental
health wise people are struggling yeah
depression anxiety with the bills and no
you know
it's okay they got a lot of they got a
lot of open loops in their life they
don't have closure on anything exactly
and that'll that'll blow your
it blows your mind it really the anxiety
gets really heavy yeah so i'm curious
you've consumed so stinking much of this
podcast in a short period of time
did it feel weird to walk in the lobby
and see all this stuff yeah i i was i
thought it was gonna be like bigger and
stuff but it's great yeah
bigger than this i know i i don't know i
don't know what i was expecting um but i
yeah like and then i was like is he does
he look intimidating i don't know what's
going on you know um so like i bro i
bring you open every conversation like
it's like oh dave and he's like is that
an uncle or something you know um
yeah who's this weird dave guy
um he is that but i i walked in and it's
like you know i was chatting with the
lady getting coffee and super nice
people and yeah you know i i listened to
your other podcast john deloney yeah
like i work in crisis and it's truly
inspiring yeah you know and i will say
this before i do my debt free stream
like if you are struggling
please reach out to your statewide
crisis outline yeah you know especially
being a veteran's day for all of those
served please reach out for help amen
because
you know it's okay to not be okay
it's important to reach out everybody's
not okay
and sometimes we uh we really need the
place to not be okay yes yeah that's
good well done brother well done i'm
proud of you man we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
uh chapter in your story to be a baby
steps millionaire now and a total money
makeover book for you to give away and
pay it forward you'll be binned to
somebody else yes you'll be in a
restaurant someday showing somebody how
their house poor and working them
through it and like ben did for you you
got to have good friends like that well
done ben
all right good stuff heath from the
portland oregon or portland maine area
i'm sorry 21 000 paid off in 12 months
making 45 to 60. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
3
two
one i'm dead
[Applause]
this is how you do it ladies and
gentlemen
this is how you do it
wow
hey
when you decide to take control of areas
of your life money being one of them
that's how you change your life be not
conformed to this world be transformed
out by the renewing of your mind
well done sir
very well done
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us america we're glad
you are here john is with us in orlando
hey john how are you
hi how you doing great man better than i
deserve what's up
uh well i um i'm gonna be uh with my
brother we're going to buy a furniture
business that my brother works at uh the
guy that owns it wants to retire and he
pretty much is just wants to sell it for
what he has in inventory
um but he wants a down payment on the
inventory of 75 000
um which i was going to pay that aspect
and me and my brother were going to be
partners in this business
but my problem is i'm trying to figure
out what the best way to get my 75 000
back but we're also still partners so i
wasn't quite sure if i should put it on
a payment plan or if i should pay my
what would be the best way to to take
that investment back because my
brother's kind of bringing in the sweat
equity and he's going to be running the
business the majority in the majority of
the time
but uh i just don't know how to go about
it i wanted to talk with you about it
so you're an absentee investor
of 75 000 into the business he's putting
nothing in it and he's going to run it
yeah i would say i'm not total absentee
because i'll be helping with uh you know
the purchasing and doing a lot of the
books and and handling on that end
and uh so i don't know if i'll be
totally optional but i think it would
probably be safe as maybe like a 70 30
split as far as the amount of work that
needs to be done
but the day to day he'll be doing
well the most fair way to do this the
proper way to do this is a little bit
complicated and you may not go for it
but i'll outline it for you okay
i would put a job description on what
each of you are going to be doing and if
you were going to hire someone to do
what that person is doing he's the
general manager you're the bookkeeper
purchaser part-time
right
and uh i would say okay that job if we
were to hire someone to do that would
pay
x and the other job would pay y and i
would pay you guys out of the business
for the work you're doing first
just like you had a job there
okay
okay then whatever profits are left
i would put a hundred percent of that
back in your pocket until your 75 000 is
returned
okay do you think also and that's
another thing is
out of let's say his inventory is a
quarter million dollars
um so we're going to have a balance and
he's gonna want a percentage of that you
know to be paid within you know maybe
two years
um
and he's doing it you know as far as
what kind of profit is this business
making
um
well i would say they're doing maybe
half a billion dollars a year
so i think he's calling in maybe
out of profit maybe 125
maybe something maybe 150.
okay i don't like people investing money
and stuff when they say maybe i think
yeah
you don't know what you're doing
yeah we haven't got the whole you know
the open book situation i know what
their margins are i know like what their
average sales are i know what they're
over
you
but uh okay that's fine if we say all
right we're going to give him
50 of the profits until he gets the
balance
and we're going to give me 50 of the
profits until i get up to 75.
and after your 75's return i'd give him
100 of the profits until you get him out
of your life because then there's no
investor in the thing it's completely
free and clear you got your 75 back he
got his money out then there's profits
then how are you going to split those
profits
50 50. i mean i'd like to be yeah i'd
like to be 50 50 with them i think
that's the fairest way to go if we're
doing this together
okay all right well then you would
continue to make your income for the job
you do
which then
you know obviously like you were paying
us an employee would lower the amount of
profit obviously not by a lot but by
whatever that job pays
and um
[Music]
and then you split the profits 50 50
after that you for being the investor
him from having brought the sweat and
the opportunity to the table to start
with
um
yeah that all makes sense now can i can
i step in a little bit further into the
weeds with you
yeah sure great okay
a couple of things that are danger areas
that you need to cover
uh one is you guys need to have a very
clear relational understanding up front
that when we're at work
he's the general manager you're the
purchasing agent and part-time
bookkeeper
you use your
general manager hat and voice
and bookkeeper hat and voice
not your brother voice
yeah
okay yeah that's the number one of my
concerns as well yeah well the way you
do it is you respect you respect the
person
yeah you don't you don't have two
brothers on the floor of the furniture
thing fighting like they're
nine-year-olds
and the rest of the employees watching
and then wonder why you can't keep good
people
so you guys have to have a respect for
each other
i'm the ceo of ramsey solutions
rachel cruz is a ramsey personality my
daughter and when she's in this office
or we're working on business items she
treats me like the ceo and i treat her
like a ramsey personality like i would a
john delonia or like i would a christie
wright i treat them her with the same
dignity i don't use my dad voice on her
and she doesn't roll her eyes like a
pendulum teenager
right
correct and so you've got to get that
relational thing down that's item number
one you need to work on that that's a
big deal and you guys need to sit and
talk that through you may even want to
write out a little bit of a narrative
that you're both in agreement to just
for clarification on how you're going to
do that
and when you you know we can argue about
football over thanksgiving dinner
but we're not going to have you know a
big brother fight here the problem with
a 50 50 business is it's a two-headed
monster and nobody's in control
if you if you're going to split the
ownership of the business 50 50
after your stock after your 5000 75 000
is returned now area number two of
concern
do a detailed in-depth written with a
lawyer partnership agreement or don't do
this deal
and you have you have to cover all of
the possible negative things that can
happen and most of them begin with a d
divorce
death
disability
disinterest i'm no longer interested
default i just refuse to work but i'd
like to keep all the money
uh yeah drug use
uh i'll be the best kind
a lawyer that has a business practice
they're used to putting together it's
called a general partnership agreement
and what you cover is the negatives
because you don't want to be in business
with his wife if he dies
period even if you love her and she
think you think she's awesome that's not
that's not what you're signing up for
so what happens if he dies well you
probably need key man insurance on both
of you life insurance term life
insurance that buys
her out of his half if he dies
it leaves you you're the owner of the
policy but it's used to make her to pay
her
you get the money to buy her out and
that's preset ahead of time
and you can preset all the you know that
that's a normal process and this is how
you end up speaking to your brothers
still when you're 90 instead of hating
each other
because you have a plan for all the
downsides you have a way to respect each
other in the operation of this because
this is fraught with danger this whole
endeavor there's a lot of downsides to
this if you don't do it right family
business can be wonderful
but it can also be cray-cray
and uh in studying family businesses
over the years i have noticed that the
family business is never more functional
than the family is
to the extent the family is
dysfunctional the family business is
screwed
and two brothers that are you know
obviously you like each other you
wouldn't be talking about this but there
are those times when you get under each
other's skin because you're brothers
it's how it works
and uh how are you gonna man manage that
conflict and how functional are you in
handling conflict with each other
that's gonna affect the business it's
going to destroy the business or it's
going to cause it to prosper
and we work with theirs that here at
ramsey every day we work hard on it to
be able to keep things moving that's a
great question you ask thank you
a lot of different things a lot of
ground cover there for a bunch of you
listening on things to do
not a big fan of partnerships but if
you're gonna do one with your brother
that's how you do it
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five kearney nebraska starting
off this hour adam is with us hi adam
how are you
not too bad how are you better than i
deserve what's up
good well um
kind of in a predicament i guess you
could call it um
so unfortunately i just recently went
through a divorce um
yeah a long story short
her
addiction
[Music]
was more important than me and my
little boy our little boy we have
together but um and things just got yeah
toxic enough to where he said enough's
enough and
anyways um that's where we're at so
my question kind of is is so
i i'm gonna retain the house mostly all
the possessions and stuff so i will have
to pay her
right around thirty seven thousand
dollars
um
and i have
um you know still about forty thousand
dollars in student loans i have a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
mutual funds and i'm wondering if um
you know do i just pull the money out of
that refinance the house
um
to do some of this
um payment stuff and you know just kind
of i guess advice on where to go um
i'm sorry man financially it's hard
thank you
yeah so basically you got all the stuff
got the the child and got all the bills
correct and she gets 37 000 bucks
that's correct which will be gone in 20
minutes yeah i'm sorry yeah yeah
uh what was she addicted to
uh alcohol yeah i'm sorry
how old are you guys
um i'm 32 she's 30.
okay how's your little boy
he is two
so
yep it was a rough two years but
so you're is what it is and reviewing
the numbers there's 150 000 in mutual
funds that's not a retirement account
correct and you have thirty seven
thousand dollars you owe her and you
have forty thousand dollars of student
loan debt no other debt except your home
um correct and that's about a hundred
and fifty thousand what are your house
um
um
so i make eighty 000 in salary and then
um my way my bonus structure is is
quarterly um i've made 40 000
um and my bonuses this year so far with
one more quarter to go so your little
boy in daycare
yes yes he is okay
all right
um
well you are um
you're in grieving mode
you're in pain
mode and um
and so it just makes it hard to do math
when you're in that and so i appreciate
you calling
um
what i would do is this uh if i woke up
in your shoes
i would write her a check i'd cash in
the some of the mutual funds
and uh eighty thousand dollars worth
of the hundred and fifty that leaves
seventy thousand in the mutual fund
and i would write her a check for thirty
seven thousand and then that's done
hands are clean right
yep um and then i'd write a check i mean
i'd write another check and pay off your
student loan
yep you're done
you still got 70 000 in a mutual fund
uh i'd pull a little bit more out and
set it aside as your rainy day fund
let's call it twenty thousand okay
i don't know i just pulled a hundred out
so now you got fifty in there
um so you have an emergency fund and
your debt free accepts your home and you
make eighty thousand plus bonuses
and then i would set myself on a
detailed
budget that i stick to
the danger in your situation is is that
the emotions that you're going through
which are normal human things because
you've been hurting
um
start to run your life rather and will
ruin your life and so you've got to put
some number systems in place like a
budget
that keep you from
grief spending
and i've done that um you've uh i've
been watching your podcast and stuff a
lot too so i already uh my truck broke
down too on top of it all so yeah you
know i had uh you know yeah a 60 000
truck ready to buy and stuff and then so
well no that's probably not a great idea
you're good gonna do an emotional
decision here and so
yeah so what did the repair cost instead
oh i sold it because it was gonna be you
know over half of what it was gonna cost
for the cost of the vehicle as a seven
thousand dollar you know truck and it
was going to cost yeah 4 000 to fix it
so i'm i'm buying my uh
grandpa's truck who can't drive right
now so what's that truck cost
uh about 16 000. that's going to cost me
10
much better decision good clear good
clear thinking there so you know if
you're aware that you would have a
tendency to do something stupid and then
you can avoid it which you just did you
just said i i'm in a weakened state
right now and i almost did a dumb thing
you just cover that that's very powerful
what you just outlined that means your
brain's working really really good right
now in the middle of a very painful and
horrible situation so just move slow
other than those couple of basic moves i
gave you pay her off pay the student
loan off set 20 000 aside as an
emergency fund get on a budget and then
let's not do anything big for a while
let's just kind of get back get the new
rhythm of life with a single dad
and you're working and you're picking
him up at daycare and you're giving him
lots of hugs and
um you know you kind of get the rhythm
of this thing and you don't have to
quote bounce back
just let yourself sit there and heal a
little
uh and and then maybe six months from
now i'm probably going to take that
other 50 out of that uh mutual fund and
i'm going to continue to work our baby
steps which means i'm going to throw
that at the house and start getting that
house paid off but i'm not doing that
today
today i want that money laying around
just a buffer between you and all this
pain
no debt emergency fund in place plus 50k
in a mutual fund living on a budget not
spending more than you have coming in
not making any big financial decisions
and just get the rhythm of your life
back the new changes with all the new
changes that have gone on and give your
heart some time to heal because your
heart's broken
and uh every time you pick your son up
and look into his eyes it you know you
cry again
because his mom's not gonna be there
because she chose the bottle
and uh it's sad
and so just just give yourself some room
to be human
personal
finance
is all so personal
there you go doesn't mean it's unique
doesn't mean the law of gravity doesn't
work for everyone it does
but uh you know your situation that
you're in you can give yourself room
margin to be human and obviously you've
done a great job with money to this
point because you've got some
so that gives you a leg up as well
good call adam appreciate you calling in
and as you're walking through this if
you need help with anything else man
we're here for you you just call in any
anytime
keep in mind when you're in pain folks
um
your critical thinking skills shut down
panic
fear
they're not your friend
grief it's not your friend
uh you you
coach your brain and you go into lizard
brain mode
instead of your ability to do high-level
critical thinking
and so it's not the time to make
good solid decisions
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 1978 i was 18 years old i got my real
estate license
we got when you're in the real estate
business in those days they gave you you
remember the board of realtors the
multiple listing service the mls
we would get once every two weeks a book
about three inches thick
called the mls book and it had all of
the houses
in the city listed by area little tiny
squares a pla of a black and white
picture uh six or nine to a page
and uh you know tiny little print of the
features of the home under each one and
you would thumb through those and look
at new listings expired listings sold
listings uh current listings and you
would be able to find a house to show
a buyer if you were a real estate agent
you were not allowed to let anyone see
that book unless they were a real estate
agent if you did you would get censored
by the board of realtors
you get fined
we protected that information and your
act the consumer's access to that
information of houses that were
available on the reel on the market you
had to go through a realtor to find that
information
boy has the world change now
a house that's for sales on 62 different
websites now
and everything about it some of the
items on the listing are wrong but some
of the pictures are even wrong wrong
house
but uh it's all over the place with the
high-tech real estate apps home browsing
sites out there you might think no one
needs a real estate agent to buy a house
that's pretty wrong
in fact nearly 90 percent of buyers who
bought a home last year used a real
estate professional
if you've got an inexperienced
or if you've got an experienced i'm
sorry and dedicated agent it's their
number one job to help you win
especially in a market as well as this
one
with these home prices doing what
they're doing and people getting
multiple offers you can leave money on
the table if you're a seller
and you can miss an opportunity if
you're a buyer or overpay if you're a
buyer
this is not amateur hour out there right
now this is a weird real estate market
and you need a pro in your corner
whether you're selling
or buying
seller almost always covers the
commission for a buyer's agent if you're
a buyer out there get in touch if you're
a seller out there get in touch
if you want to find some of the top real
estate agents in america we have vetted
them and i know that market i know that
world inside now and we've got the high
octane high protein high performance
best performing real estates in your
area
real estate agents in your area we call
them endorsed local providers
elps they're ramsey trusted if you want
to find a great real estate agent go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent
and you'll find a trusted pro who can
help you
buy a home or sell a home
ramseysolutions.com
slash agent
louise is with us in new york city hi
louise what's up
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
so i
recently got engaged to my girlfriend of
almost news
we've been living together already for
two years since i moved here to new york
city
we're both
in debt i have
just over 20 grand in student loans and
a little over 35 000 and
credit cards
i don't know how much she owes but she
has a couple of cards that are
almost maxed out or basically maxed out
i don't think it's
maybe just over 10
total she doesn't have any student loans
we don't have a
car
so any any other loans and we make about
150
uh
gross or i mean household
before taxes
the question is i i've been following
baby steps or money makeover and i've
tried
to budget i have the app and i've tried
to
um do it on my own
just for my finances i haven't really
been able to
follow through other than baby step
number one um stick to the budget
and uh
what do you mean what do you mean the
question is
77 okay
so why have you not been able to move
beyond saving a thousand dollars
i think because i haven't um
cut out or cut up my credit cards
you're not living on them you wrote out
a budget but you're not living on it
right you're you're still doing the same
old crap after you wrote the budget and
put it in the drawer
yes yeah that's normal so i'm like you
already know what you gotta do to fix it
right
right yeah so my question is i wanna i
mean since we're now engaged then uh
we're getting married next may i i want
to
and i've tried to
to do it together i mean
she doesn't really manage on
on her own
i i wouldn't
i wouldn't combine your finances until
you're married
right but what about like budgeting or i
wouldn't combine your finances i
wouldn't combine your finances until
you're married
you shouldn't pay her bills she
shouldn't pay your bills
i i don't need that but like we have
household expenses and um
i mean well that's just splitting it
with your roommate all of that
that's just splitting it with your
roommate when she's your wife it's
different but right now she's your
roommate
and so how do best
um discuss with her i mean even even if
we're not combining but how to best
discuss with our
and adjust our lifestyle
because even if
we're going to be at odds where i if i'm
trying to do something that she's trying
i mean continues with our
you have to have a vision beyond friday
night
thank god it's friday oh god it's monday
you're living short term both of you and
when you start saying hey i think we
could be out of debt and i think we
could be wealthy and i think we could
work together and and this money piece
be a high level of communication and add
to our relationship and i'm going to
really start sticking this budget i
haven't done a good job so far but i'm
going to write out my budget i'm going
to start sticking to it i'm going to
really do this stuff and i'll be
cheering you on i hope you do too
because when we're married we're going
to be doing that we need to be working
together to win long term because
couples who do not work together on
money usually don't stay married
and if they do they have a crummy
marriage
because if you can agree on your
spending and agree on your money goals
what you're really agreeing on is your
priorities your fears the things you
love your goals and you're ready to go
so uh i think the best thing louise can
do is work on luis right now instead of
fixing somebody else
because you got some work to do on you
brother
so get that budget out of the drawer
start living on it cut up the stupid
credit cards plastic surgery tonight by
candlelight
right in front of your fiance
you don't have to cut hers up you're
cutting yours up you're setting the
you're setting the trail you're setting
the uh example
mckenzie is with us mackenzie is in
knoxville hi mckenzie how are you
hi dave um
i
me and my husband are just a little
confused on what to do
next after baby step three
do we move on to four five and six or
do we do baby step three b where we save
up for for a house either one's okay
either one okay we had our original goal
was to pay 100 for a house and that was
going to take us three to five years to
save up but i didn't know if we needed
to have that entirely saved up before we
started investing it just seemed like a
long time before we started i mean it's
gonna obviously if you start investing
it's gonna slow your pace of savings
towards the house
so sometimes couples do both sometimes
they just roll up their sleeves and say
we're gonna do this in three years we're
gonna get her done
you know let's just get after it here
you got to sit down look at your numbers
but
you can do 3b and go ahead and start
four
or not
i wouldn't stay i wouldn't do zero
retirement savings
for more than about three years
if you think you can save up the house
or about be done in three years then i
would probably roll up my sleeves and
get after it i think that'd be great if
you paid cash for a house
in three years that'd be pretty neat
put you in an amazing position going
forward too the wealth you'd be able to
build would be amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at zip recruiter dot
com slash ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage michael and carly are
with us hey guys how are you great how
are you better than i deserve welcome
where do you guys live tuscaloosa
alabama roll tide dave all right look at
you man i like it well welcome to
nashville here good to have you guys so
all the way up here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off uh
just over 335 000. whoa how long did
this take uh just over three years good
for you and your range of income during
that time i started about 200 up to
right around 230 maybe just a little
over okay cool what do you do for a
living i'm a pharmacist i'm a teacher
all right good for you guys
all right that's a lot of money yes so
was that pharmacy school or did you pay
off your house that would be pharmacy
school most of it about 252 000 worth of
it yeah wow okay and some was just uh
undergrad playing around when i first
started too so it kind of led into a
little that too very good okay cool what
grade do you teach i teach middle school
so i have sixth seventh and eighth
graders you are a brave woman
the best she's a brave lady i like it
all right so we got pharmacy school debt
with some of it what was the rest of the
debt uh it was a piece of property we
bought probably a year after we got
married we had to have a piece of
property and everybody was you know has
some property so we had to do it too
that's about 73 000 worth of it you keep
it or did you sell it we sold it all
right what'd it bring uh we actually
sold it less than what we bought it for
it was not a good not a good feeling it
was not a good buy
but you know it was actually an
eye-opening experience and and we
learned from it so
um we ended up paying
about eight thousand dollars left on the
loan so it wasn't as bad as
it could have been but it actually sped
things up a little bit yeah that got rid
of a chunk of it yeah very good and you
guys have a great income yes sir so how
long have you been married uh
it'll be seven years on the 22nd okay so
you've been married three or four years
and something happens you bump into this
ramsey process tell me your story how
did you get plugged in to us
um for myself it was right after i
graduated pharmacy school i went over to
my friend josh's house and
you know like say i saw a book on the
shelf and i said man what is this right
here i was like it looks awesome it's
got total money makeover you know debt
free and he's like i don't know he said
you want to read it you certainly can
have it so i took it home i read it um
i read it and i thought it was a great
book but you know i didn't do anything
else with it and let's say i was going
you know just going through the motions
going through the motions and um
you know one day it finally clicked
you know my wife will tell you too that
my student loans every month you know it
was it was quite a bit every month and
we went to the accounting one day and
you know he said uh you get paid you
paid 20 some thousand dollars worth of
uh you know your student loans this year
but um about a thousand dollars went to
principal i was like god you know just
it was just heartbreaking to make 200
years of that right yeah yeah you know
all the money that you uh you worked so
hard for was going to somebody else and
uh you know really for me that was the
that was the hardest part of it was just
knowing that you worked so hard and you
were given to somebody else yeah
okay so you guys come home from visiting
the accountant and have the wake-up call
and then what'd you do
um got on a budget
and said you know what
enough is enough um you know like say
when i first graduated my idea was to
just
get on an income based repayment because
i had roommates that did the same thing
they said this is what we're going to do
i'd never heard of income based
repayments i was like that sounds great
to me and after 10 15 years it was all
gonna get forgiven um
but then after that like i say we
started paying all this money and uh
my interest rate you know stayed the
same but i paid so much but the
principal actually kept going you know
the money kept going up i actually owed
more and more and more it's like what in
the world is going on i was like i was
talking about earlier today that you
know i paid double payments and it went
up it's a scam i was like what in the
world is going on here
so for me that was it and you know she
was going to work to pay my student
loans and basically she was working for
free and wow i couldn't do it anymore
and say we had a talk and you know we
certainly got on the same page about it
for sure okay
so carly what was the hardest part of
this process over three years because
you guys have been on beans and rice
yeah um
really just kind of agreeing what needs
to go in the budget how much like how
much we're going to spend for
restaurants how much are we going to
spend for like miscellaneous like if we
want to go
buy something that's that was really it
but the more we did it the easier it
becomes
so now i mean it's really not that
difficult at first it was but once you
do it it's
it's not that bad well done guys
well done so what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of that is
um get a plan
uh work together
go to work
hey man you're in debt don't go don't
think about vacation go to work yeah you
know from like say you see somebody
doing all this for myself i know um
when you see somebody that's doing these
you know 30-year financial homes zero
down you know no interest rate loans for
you know furniture and leasing cars that
was you know for me like that that's it
you know do something different be
different you know don't be like
everybody else anybody can take the easy
way out but just like i said get up go
to work
don't do debt because you're going to
work for somebody else and that's why
they have like you said that's why they
have the big buildings yeah because
they're taking your money that's exactly
right they're living off of you and
you're making 200 grand that's right
yeah and now you're making 200 grand you
got no payments in the world amen how
does that feel good
it feels awesome
you know it feels like it feels like a
chain like you say you know like you
show you see a chainsaw and things like
that it really is
people don't realize
that you know you have this money you
say you have this money in your savings
account but if you have people that you
owe you don't have anything you don't
have anything they call your loan
your i mean it's theirs yeah you don't
have anything right until you get rid of
it exactly and now you do
well done guys who's your biggest
cheerleaders
um i would think
for me it would be my dad he is very
he is very much a cash money person if
you don't have the money you don't buy
it
um and i wouldn't necessarily say
cheerleader but i would say motivation
because i just know i know what he's
thinking when we're making these
payments on things and i just i know
what he's thinking
just just well then he's proud right now
yes he is yeah i bet
very cool well well done you two very
well done we're proud of you thank you
you're heroes you took control of your
lives very very cool we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story to go on and
be baby steps millionaires now and
you're well on your way this great
income and no payment and now you got
control of your money absolutely and you
know how to work together you've got
three years in the trenches to prove
that so
very very cool also copy total money
makeover for you to give away off your
shelf someday and uh maybe some guy i'll
read it and it'll start something you
never know right that's the way that
stuff works always pay it forward good
good job well done all right it's
michael and carly tuscaloosa alabama 335
000
paid off whoo a lot of student loans
three years they did it making 200 to
230. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
love it
very very very well done
congratulations you guys we really
appreciate you that's fabulous
guys uh the student loan thing
continues to be out of control in
america and some of you have kind of
been able to sweep it under the rug
because you've not had to make payments
or not had to make interest had interest
on it in the last little while with all
the pandemic uh
crap that came down out of washington dc
uh and it allowed you to ignore
this elephant standing in the middle of
your living room
standing on your chest
and you could ignore it you can't ignore
it anymore you've got to deal with these
student loans you've got to deal with
them
and if you've got a student that's
thinking about getting into the student
loans uh jump online and watch borrowed
future our documentary
you can watch it at amazon prime at
google play on apple tv
uh
it'll blow your mind
how crooked
the whole student loan thing is 1.7
trillion dollars in debt now and
everybody's just being real quiet about
it right now
it was a big deal about a year and a
half ago
but then the pandemic comes along and
everybody's like oh we don't have a
problem anymore no it's all still there
it's all still there and they're still
making these loans they're running
around talking about forgiving student
loans for giving student loans while
they're still making them that's
intellectually dishonest
that's wrong
how can you talk about forgiving
something
because it's so bad while you continue
with the other hand to keep making the
loan
see the first thing you need to do
congress is stop the stupidity
then you can talk about for forgiveness
but until then you can't even talk about
it intelligently with integrity oh wait
a minute i said integrity in congress in
the same sentence that was a bad idea
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here open phones at eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money
mo is with us mo is in milwaukee hi mo
how are you
dave i'm doing good how are you better
than i deserve what's up
great to hear well i do want to continue
the trend from the last call and
say that i'm debt free thankfully as of
this morning way to go congratulations
thank you sir um i paid off about twenty
three thousand dollars in the last five
and a half months
um all student loans
and my question for you today is what's
next i don't know what to do i'm really
young i'm making decent money um
and i don't know where to put it so um
hoping you could help dave well well
done well by getting rid of the debt you
now have control of your most powerful
wealth building tool
your income
so what do you make mo
i make about 67 right now what do you do
i'm an engineer
started started about six months ago and
right out of school i started paying off
my student loans and
wanted to get them done out of the way
by december and um i was a month early
on my plan so way to go thankfully it
worked out thank you so what are you 23
24
i'm 22. oh wow still young the youngest
high in my team yeah you're glad you
graduated early well good good good good
for you okay so what we teach is a thing
called the baby steps which is the
shortest path between where you are in
wealth and that's the idea so that you
live like no one else so later you can
live and give
like no one else outrageous generosity
and a good lifestyle that's what we're
after here
and so uh now that you're debt free your
next goal would be to have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
it's a simple savings account
with some money in it just for a rainy
day
and so if you're making if you're making
67 if we said your expenses are three
grand a month then you'd need nine grand
so i'd say you need ten to fifteen
thousand dollars in that account that's
your next goal
okay and if you got that sitting there
just for emergencies if you need to save
and buy anything else if you need to
upgrade a car if you're needing to buy
some furniture anything like that you're
just out of school then you would save
and pay cash for that after that
emergency fund is in place
uh then that means that's the plan okay
then that moves us on to baby step four
start saving 15 of your income into
retirement and um beyond that i would
start saving towards uh the first house
okay and i guess my question for that is
what percent of the rest of my income
should i put away into savings for that
new house
i mean 15 of my income
and rent
after i save up that three to six months
expenses still leaves me with
a whole hell of a lot at the end of the
month and i don't know how much to put
away
for that house how much to give
how much to invest in other accounts
um well there's not a there's you know
that these are personal choices
obviously the more you save the less you
have to spend and give the more you give
the less you have to give and spend
and so are the less you have to save and
spend so you know you're you need to do
something on all three categories you
need to have a reasonable life you make
good money you're a sharp young guy
there's you don't need to be living on
you know ramen noodles there's no need
to you've done a good job
number two you i'd always have
generosity in your budget
and then number three we're saving for a
house and obviously the more we put in
that house account the more money is
going to be there no kidding
and so um you know just start messing
with it a little bit start playing with
it you can play with one percentage one
month and change it around
uh i'm an evangelical christian so i
tithe i give a tenth of my income as a
baseline
to my local church that's the first
thing i do on my generosity list
beyond that we do other giving as well
but but that's the baseline that's a
starting point for me
and uh so you could you could weave that
into your equation if you wanted to or
something like that uh but yeah you're
right on it you're you know here's the
thing you're going to be fine
uh you're an engineer which means you
know numbers you're intentional you're
22 years old you're calling this show
and thinking about these things you're
going to be an absolute rock star you're
going to be a baby steps millionaire
you're going to get there hang on i'll
send you a copy of the total money
makeover which is the actual template
every detail and nuance of the baby
steps how to do the stuff we talk about
here on the air every day the total
money makeover hold on kelly i'll give
you a copy congratulations sir
thomas is in virginia alexandria to be
precise hi thomas how are you
i'm very good sir uh thank you for
taking my call really appreciate what
you do how are you doing sir better than
i deserve what's up well i have a
student loan question uh since we are on
the topic today and uh just to let you
know i'm uh just recently married a
month ago oh congratulations
well thank you and my wife has always
been very disciplined with money
and uh i have been the opposite of that
backing up uh
debts from
credit card to
student loan debt and
medical debt because i was uninsured for
a while and about a year over a year ago
uh we had a tension point while we were
still dating uh with how we spend money
and
so after reading your book uh really
took to the debt snowball and i'd been
paying off that before that but paid off
about
20 000 worth of medical and student loan
debt so right now i only have the
student loan debt left good for you
and our question was is so when we came
together we she had a financial advisor
and she
has money and savings and retirement
with
right now the retirement's had over
half a million dollars and
she
did the entire six-month emergency fund
so
with the remaining debt that i have
we could pay it off but the financial
advisor told us that
you know with everything that's
happening in dc and this talk of student
loan forgiveness up to fifty thousand
dollars that maybe it would be smart to
wait a year to see if it actually
happens
and
just wondering what you think about that
well
um i think if you think that that's
going to happen inside of a year
that um
you're dreaming
uh you know have you ever heard the
phrase it takes an act of congress and
the phrase means it takes forever
and it's not likely to happen
well this takes an act of congress
and it takes forever and it's not likely
to happen this is a political disaster
looking for a place to happen for
somebody
and uh it's not going to happen in a
year it would all they would already if
it was going to happen in a year there'd
already be bills on the floor
and they're just not they're not all
they're doing is popping their gums like
they always do they just run around
running their mouth just running their
mouth running their mouth and they don't
never do anything they just talk
and and just get on fox news and yell at
each other that's all they do
and so you're waiting around on those
people to fix your life not a chance
dude uh i think you probably need a new
financial advisor and i'd write a check
today and pay off the debt
okay no that's good advice and that's
what i was thinking too is that you know
and his viewpoint was as well you know
with the midterm elections you know
maybe with uh
um you know something will change within
the years so just to hold off wait wait
wait wait wait wait a minute the
republicans are not for student loan
forgiveness by and large
and with the ratings of the current
administration the midterm elections are
not going to bring in more democrats
unless something changes so it's going
to go the other way it's going to move
away from student loan forgiveness at
the midterm elections so once again
this guy's not a political analyst
either apparently so no i'm i'm not uh
you know you do what you want to do but
you called and asked me if i if i woke
up in your shoes i'd write a check today
i'm not sitting around waiting on
washington to fix my life
you have a long wait man
a long wait
so i i would just be done with this you
borrowed the money you could pay the
money back there's a neat idea and uh
move on with your life man let's go
let's go that's what i would do
thanks for calling in sir we appreciate
you
so um
there are some extreme situations
and i love grace
i like for folks to get a fresh start i
i the idea that some of you could have
your student loans wiped out
it you know it's
for those of you that are in pain with
this stuff i understand
but on the other hand
there's some principles involved in this
and
one of the principles is we shouldn't
keep making the loans before we have a
discussion about
forgiving them
that's intellectually dishonest
and again check out borrowed future
give it a watch tonight give the old
documentary a look see
you'll see what we're talking about it's
a mess out there y'all it's a mess and
congress made the mess
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america this is common sense
for your dollars and cents it's the
ramsey show
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five brett is in tampa florida
hi brett how are you
good dave i asked you how you were doing
but i think i know the answer to the
question some things are predictable my
brother what's up that's right so thank
you for taking my call
um i i have the opportunity to purchase
a business that i've been working for
for 15 years
i'm pretty much running the company for
the last five years
the current owners
taking a lot of time off so i'm running
the company he's giving me the
opportunity to buy the company
the i've got to come up with
cash operating capital he's going to
take a note back on the remaining amount
of money for the company so i'm short by
about 150 000
so my question is is
i've got a house that
has a mortgage of about 370 000
uh it's appraising for 710
would it be wise to
get the additional money i need out
of the equity of my house
i don't understand why when you buy a
business you need operating capital
explain that to me
uh it's more of a safety net than
anything else
um and it's and it's part of the
negotiations that i'm having with him
that that's what the minimum amount of
money he wants for operating capital in
the business
oh
okay
so you don't actually need the money in
the business he just wants you to have
retained earnings in the business
yes yeah yes okay i mean as long as i
operate the business correctly which
i've been doing for a long time
you know we should never get below
the operating capital that i put into
the company
so what is the what is the business
gross revenues and what's the net
profits
uh the net is around uh
about 300 000 a year and how much are
you paid
170
okay what can you live on
uh
probably a hundred and thirty
probably a hundred
well
okay
so 370 thousand dollars
and uh how much is he or 300 000 bucks
what what is he uh
what's he want for this business
500
okay
and that net profit figure you gave me
you're you're
you're intimately aware of that because
you're running the place right that's
correct
after you're paid 170 000 it makes 300
000.
that's correct and he wants a half a
million dollars
correct
okay it's a good deal
good price
uh usually i hear usually when i get
these stories it's not a good price i
was getting that's where i was headed
because i was getting ready to run you
off from this deal but i'm not going to
now um
we just have to change the negotiation
because i'm not going to have you go
borrow on your house to do it i think
that's a bad idea especially for
retained earnings that are just going to
sit there and look at you to make the
guy feel comfortable after you've been
running the dadgum thing for five years
you ought to be comfortable
he pays you 170 000 a year so i'm not
buying this crap so i would propose a
counter offer in the negotiation
and it would sound like um this
i'm willing to uh pay myself only 100
000
and that leaves approximately 350 to 400
000 in profit to work with the very
first 150 000 out of that profit i will
pledge to retained earnings for
operating capital
after that is established which is less
than six months
later right after that is established i
will give you 100 of the profits above
my 100 000 salary until you are paid off
which will pay him off in about three
years or less
about two years actually about two years
because we need we need 650 000
to have 150 in operating capital and pay
him 500 right
that's right okay
and if the business is making
350 then you do that in two years
right
right yeah he's paid he's paid out
he's paid out in two years
he's paid out and you have before that
happened put 150 in there and he's paid
out in two years i'm gonna give you a
hundred percent of the profits until
you're paid
right right
and and and if he's not willing to do
that and he's adamant about it
then i walk
yeah and i'm gonna go get a different
job and he's gonna get this business
back in his lap that he hasn't run in
five years and doesn't know what the
crap he's doing he's gonna have a
serious problem in the bathroom right
after you do this
all right believe me he wants to do this
deal
yes he does yeah he'll need adult
diapers otherwise
right
yeah okay listen i'm telling you man he
don't want this thing back
he wants to sell it to you
and he's going to get all his money in
two years
and you're going to meet your your
capital requirement in the first six
months
that's there's nothing unreasonable
about this the only what's the reason
for the capital requirement the reason
for it if there's a business reason not
an emotional reason is he wants to know
that the business is stable because
you've got some you got some slush money
there you've got retained earnings for
problems right
right and you're going to put that in
there in six months
it's not like it's gonna take you six
years to establish this and it's not
like he's gonna be on the hook for six
years either
yes and i would assume i could put some
language in the contract uh for the same
two yeah the contract would read the
first 100 and i will live i will take no
more than a hundred thousand
one hundred percent of the profits will
be applied to this formula one the first
one hundred fifty 000 of 100 of the
profits will go into retained earnings
following that 100 of the profits will
come to you until it gets to 500 000
which if profits stay the same by the
way we've just done the math is two
years or less
and he may want the profit to go towards
his note as first position rather than
uh uh operating capital i don't care
it's fine with me he's the one brought
up the stupid operating capital we
didn't
you want to take the operating capital
out of the equation completely he can
have his money in 18 months
yeah
i'll just give you 100 of the profits
you'll be gone in 18 months and i'll
deal with the operating capital if i
need to get some i'll go borrow on my
house but that ain't your problem bubba
i'm running the business
got it you got this what kind of
business is this
construction good
oh and by the way we're in a boom time
hello yeah this is awesome
what kind of construction residential
commercial what
commercial oh
yeah
yeah ding ding ding equipment coming
with us
too uh very very little okay a paper
contractor all right good hey man
get her done i think you got a good deal
here but just don't stay don't you know
you're in the driver's seat he's not
that's my point
so let's get this thing and get it right
you get him out of the picture as fast
as you can
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's bethel betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we've all heard the saying it's
better to give than to receive
and you know what it's more fun too
and while you can have a great time
giving the latest gadgets or gizmos to
the folks on your christmas list you can
also give them something that actually
has an impact something that will change
their lives for the better that's why
our team is putting everything on sale
today
go ahead and get your christmas gift
shopping done while our best sellers are
up to 73 percent off
we have gifts for him gifts for her
gifts for kids of all ages but this is a
one-day sale so don't wait to get
started today
some of our top deals include our famous
starter envelope system for only 5.99
and of course you can shop our famous 10
sale get over 40 of our best-selling
books for just 10 bucks or less
forget the one-time use presents get a
gift a life give a gift of li of a
lifetime of hope
shop today veterans day sale at
ramseysolutions.com
be sure and check it out
ramseysolutions.com
cara is with us cara is in ann arbor
michigan hi kara what's up
hi dave thanks so much for taking my
call i really appreciate you and all of
your team thank you so i'm calling
because we found you a little bit later
in our financial journey and our
financial journey has been filled with a
lot of dumb but thankfully a little
smart
and your baby steps and coaching have
changed everything so we're debt-free
now and we have a healthy retirement
fund but i also have a junior and senior
in high school with no college fund
so what my wondering is is i've run our
numbers and i feel like we can slow down
baby step number four
in order to help cash flow their um
college years
and i've actually done this but with a
lot of anxiety which is why i'm calling
you because i'm wondering is this wise
and am i on the right track with my
thinking
what's your household income
230 000
okay so 15 is 34 000 right 25 000
okay
and what do you what are you what are
you spending on college
um well because they're so close
together i'm trying to save about 18 000
for each per year
because they'll be paying some in too
yeah what are you planning to spend on
college
uh total for them i mean that's my total
spent for four years so um
18 000 no 18 000 times four
okay so i'm in it 36 000 a year since
they're back to that
okay so
you make 230 and if you uh
saved
36 for college and 35 for retirement
that's only 70
of the 230.
how is it you can't eat
oh no we can definitely eat
uh and i'm putting it away for sure i
think my anxiety is more around slowing
down the retirement i slowed it down so
you're suggesting we could keep the
35 000. that would be 15 of your
household income yeah and i exploded
down to 20k
per year
okay but if you saved if you saved 35
into retirement at 15
and you spent 36 on your kid
kids for college per year
that's 70 000 out of 230
okay
why why can you not make that
um i think when i run our numbers on our
budget
um
it feels like our tax bills are really
high
um
and you know when i add it all up it's
like 26 000 a year and all my things
i've put into our thinking fund and
what do we have sinking funds for
um
we have a 20 year old house we've got
old cars that are paid for
you know driveways that need to be
replaced and things like that we haven't
done because we didn't do smart early on
we haven't been putting money aside for
home repairs let's change our strategy
from sinking funds on this to projects
okay and say we need we need to replace
a car during the time they're in college
we need to replace a roof during the
time they're in college and you just put
that in your 230.
i think you can do this i think you're
over analyzing this
it sounds like you've got money going
into about 63 different pockets
there's fuels like that for sure yeah
and i think i want to clean that up and
simplify it to a project based idea
rather than a sinking fund idea in your
case it's good to have some sinking
funds for certain things
some little mini savings accounts to
cover an upcoming expense that's all the
sinking fund is for those of you out
there but the uh but but and that's not
a bad idea at all
uh but it but if it's causing you to
stop saving for retirement for the next
six to seven years
or to slow your savings for return next
six to seven years i don't i don't think
i want to do that
um what is the um how much is in the
balance on the retirement account now
we have eight hundred thousand okay all
right and i have a pension
yeah so that i'll get intense you know
when i retire so you're millionaires
we are yes
what's your house worth
a 550. good good okay we've done a great
job i mean this is kind of almost
theoretical discussion so i i with 800
000 sitting there in a paid for house
sitting there i'm i can understand if
you want to dial it back it's not the
end of the world
i'm just i'm just trying to challenge
your thinking a little bit and see let's
see if it's sound i'm just beating up
against the edge of it and see if it'll
see if it'll fall over but but um
yeah i mean
if you do if you do what you're going to
do you're certainly not going to retire
broke you're already a millionaire you
know you've already done it you're a
great job
but just uh don't
you know you got no house payment so you
got even more wiggle room in this budget
too
right
so yeah i i i think i would probably
re-look your sinking funds and let's
let's not over and not not have too much
of that detail going on it's probably
paralyzing you a little bit and do that
to a project based you see what i mean
when i say that yeah yeah and then let's
see if you can get back to your 15
and do it and still make it that's what
i'm gonna work towards
uh but if you don't
uh if you're down at um uh 10 or
something or whatever and you know
you're still going to have millions and
millions of dollars
so oh darn i hate it when that happens
so good work good work good work overall
phil is with us in ocean city hi phil
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks so much for having me good
afternoon good afternoon what's up
so i am uh i have i have a good problem
i was just selected for a new position
at a new location
uh but my
my conflict is that i'm not sure
whether or not i should take it and i'm
at approaching zero hour to make a
decision for the hr
uh three girls under seven uh the
the this is going to require a move
because it's 150 miles round trip um
and i have a deployment coming up next
fall
and the new position is a promotion but
it's no immediate race because of the
cost of living adjustment
so
as i'm saying this out loud i'm leaning
more and more towards not taking the
position for the well being my family
but i yeah why would you move for no
money
that as i was leaving my mouth by yes
yeah i mean i would ask my supervisor
that why would i move for no money
the potential for there to be a uh
it's it's a government position so i get
selected at a gs level yeah and then
over the course of a few years there's
automatic raises uh and that would be
the benefit over the course of say seven
years but immediately there's no benefit
yeah
and i bet you that comes up again
later if you don't take it now
good point sir yes absolutely and then
my wife and i were just trying to talk
it out and as are you active duty
no sir i'm national guard okay i was
thinking the way you were describing
this so you got a civilian government
federal government position and then
your national guard
correct okay all right thank you for
your service
um thank you so much
yeah i i
i don't know i mean there's not much
negotiation because it's the government
it's not like they're going to come in
and change something this is what
they're going to do or they're not going
to do it
but i don't see
there's nothing here that makes me smile
uproot your little baby family right
before you go and you move them all for
no money just for future potential later
with the
government uh
i'll probably wait and you take the next
one as it comes along after you get back
from deployment and everybody's got a
little more energy and maybe they'll
actually offer some money to go with it
that's probably me but it's not the end
of the world but that's probably what i
would do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage chad and siobhan are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you better than i deserve welcome
it's good to have you in nashville where
do you guys live we live in windham
maine windham maine now what is that
near it's uh 15 miles outside of uh
portland ah okay it's a big guy owning a
couple hours ago from portland we met
them we couldn't believe it that's
pretty cool and two debt free screens
from portland maine area today very good
lobster capital of the world huh that's
right baby love it love that town it's
great hey so how much debt did you guys
pay off we paid off 207 thousand dollars
of debt we also cash flowed over a
hundred thousand dollars for a total of
three hundred and seven thousand dollars
whoa cash flowed what we cash flowed
some uh upgrades and renovations to our
house that was fifty thousand twenty
thousand was some vehicles i had some
dave cars i'm a road warrior uh ten
thousand was a surprise uh disney trip
when we got halfway through the
baby steps we also did uh two sets of
braces
uh a hip
and um
and a couple of appliances lately it's
been kind of funny yeah wow so is this
house and everything yes sir way to go
wow all right how long did this take
nine years way to go you guys
excellent and your range of income
during that nine years we started out at
55 000 and we're at 136. i
love it what do you guys do for a living
i work at a chiropractic office front
desk
i'm a sales associate for a moving
company and i'm also a part-time
bartender all right very very good
what's this house worth about 300 000.
way to go you guys how old are you two
i'm 46. i'm 40. ah in a paid for house
yes sir you're so weird i love it you
know when you said that i was like wow i
wonder what he means by that and when we
paid it off we went to celebrate and um
we told the girls that they could get
dessert now
and so
the maitre d was bringing the dessert
out and she looked at one of my
daughters and said what's the occasion
and she said we just paid off the house
and the looks that we were getting and
the people next door and the tables were
whispering and that's when i realized
what you really meant
well normal's broke man you don't want
to be normal you want to be weird way to
go you guys
this is so fun what a great journey so
what started you with ramsay nine years
ago i'm gonna look at my notes
on february 27 2012 our middle daughter
paige had to have hip surgery at boston
children's oh my goodness yeah
about six days before that um
my husband's insurance
we had to renegotiate a new policy
so actually while we were staying in the
hospital we ended up hitting two
deductibles
yep it's uh the luck of the draw
so
along with the hospital debt though we
weren't budgeting
we weren't on the same page
you know we weren't working together
and so basically um i got notifications
six days before we were headed down
this was the second surgery for paige so
we spent 10 months prior going through
this process and then in november
beforehand they uh told us that it
didn't work and that they were referring
us down to boston so it was a pretty big
blow siobhan took it very hard we all
did
but
what happened was
the 21st of february i got notification
from my employer that they were
negotiating hard on the insurance and
they just came to a point where they
made a decision that they were going to
change our health care coverage
and so i got notifications six days
beforehand that instead of a standard
ppo
they were going to go to a high
deductible
hmo with an hsa
and when i got the notification my heart
went in my throat yeah
yeah so that's an extra five grand more
than that because what happened was we
were looking at well it was uh
5900
because what happened was that uh we
were going to hit the first deductible
35 right and then they did a bridge for
24 6. that's what we were thought
and then
when we went down to boston children's i
went to the family care center and just
said listen you know i need to
understand what's going on here
and so the family care center had a
couple of gals from the billing
department come down sit down the one
thing they looked at me and said was
chad you're going to have to keep coming
down here this process she's so young
what she's going to go through you're
going to have to come back down here we
think it's going to be closer to 10 over
18 months
wow and
just
the blow
yeah really um i hit bottom yeah we had
maxed out credit cards three maxed out
credit cards we had uh ten thousand on a
home equity line we had the mortgage
um and i was basically
a couple of times a couple months
beforehand i had to use the home equity
line to pay some of the credit card
bills
because we were disorganized we weren't
working together sure and
so basically
after the meeting
at the family care center i walked up to
the um
to the hospital room because pete just
got out of surgery
and uh they were going to only let one
of us stay
so
siobhan wasn't going to go anywhere
so i walked up into the um
the medical room
and just stood there and looked at him
and uh
basically my wife was in a pullout
caught
and my daughter was in a full body cast
from her chest to her ankles with tubes
and monitors
and uh
that was that was it that was it
basically uh this is about to change
there was a line in the sand that got
crossed
and
now i'm mad and uh yeah and basically
that's a hit bottom and i looked at him
and i just said never again
we're athertons we're done with this
stuff we're not playing any more games
we're not playing uh you know
we're gonna hit this head on
and we're gonna go after this and i
don't care what it takes
and so i i gave my my girls a kiss
and i went to the hotel to try to figure
out what we were gonna do
how how'd you find us
i was in the hotel room
i had my hot shower in my moment
and
i went i came out and i opened up my uh
my laptop and i did two google searches
and your uh your website popped up and
on the second try thank god my mother
uh
i was a little bit sharper i didn't go
to three it only took me two but
uh on the second try i happened to look
and see your podcast symbol and i'd
never listen to podcasts and so
i just sat there and i looked at it and
i said okay so i searched you
and i just i don't know why i hesitated
but i did and i just said you know what
hit it and i hit it and i heard the
saxophone
and the intro and i heard
you take your first couple calls and
what you would do is you'd empathize and
you'd methodically pull the facts
and put it on your yellow pad
that you had and you would just you'd go
through the facts and you'd empathize
but then you'd kick him in the butt
and this one lady you said uh you said
you're being a princess
being a prince i'm like i'm like yeah
that's what i'm like this is it i need i
need someone to tell me the truth
and so and then i heard my first
debt-free scream and i'm sitting there
i'm crying and this one guy that was
doing the debt-free scream he just said
drink the kool-aid drink the kool-aid
and he goes just follow through and and
he did it and i go you know what that's
what i need to do i just need to and so
um right then and there i just said
we're doing this
and nine years later here you are yep
wow that's powerful dude
that's powerful i'm honored wow very
very cool
all right
so let's get the kiddos up into the shot
what are their names and ages nowadays
so
this is haley
is 16.
this is sophia sophia is 11.
and this is paige
and paige is
you're how old is 14. 14. there's so
many
it
well well done you guys what a great
family story your mom and dad have paid
a price to change your family tree
ladies
and uh powerful powerful story that's
pretty cool dude proud of you guys that
means very very well done we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
because the next step is for you to be
baby steps millionaires and you're on
your way to do that you're the kind of
people we're here for we love you very
very well done excellent excellent all
right gang chad and siobhan from
portland maine 207 plus 100 000 in cash
flow
307 over nine years making 55 to 136 all
from a line in the sand no more count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today second timothy 2 15
do your best to present yourself to god
as one approved a worker who does not
need to be ashamed and who correctly
handles the word of truth
john maxwell says most people who decide
to grow personally find their first
mentors
in the pages of books
well that would be true
i did
and still do for that matter
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
morgan is with us in pittsburgh hi
morgan how are you
hi i'm good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so i've had a question my boyfriend and
i um
we just not kind of recently graduated
college where i'm a year and a half out
and he's two years out
and i have a lot of student debt and he
has a little bit in a car payment and
we're trying to eventually move out of
my parents house and we're just
wondering the next big steps we could
take to tackle all our debt
hmm you both graduated
yeah
i graduated he graduated two years ago
and i graduated may 2020.
so what do you make how much money do
you make
i make 70 grand a year and he makes
roughly 65. okay
all right
so you have a 135 000 household income
if you were married
correct okay
so
go get married
tell him that i've been waiting on it
well he needs to move out if he's not
gonna get married
yeah yeah we both live at my parents
house luckily so we don't have any i
know he needs to move out if he's not
gonna get married
no i'm serious
uh you can't you know
i got to tell you here's the here's the
statistical evidence
all right the number of people who do
what you all are doing and succeed
financially
is almost zero
okay like that everybody talks about it
but nobody does it so if you want the
formula to win there's a thing called
the marriage advantage in the financial
world
and we see people who are married
prosper over those who are not
there's a marriage advantage health
increases everything and so yeah i i
would get married the first thing i
would do and then you have 135 000
household income i don't know why you
would be living at your mother's in that
situation you'd go get a an apartment
and then you would attack your student
loan debt and making 135 000 how quickly
can you pay off a step pretty dead gum
quick if you start concentrating on it
right
when you clean up both student loans how
much student loan debt have you got
again
i have a lot i have a hundred and fifty
thousand he only has twenty thousand
okay so 170 000 combined and how much
other debt
um
that's all i have and then he has a
truck payment or
truck loan for 20 000.
okay so 190 000 gets you guys out of
debt if you keep the truck
all right
and you make 135
if you're married
and you live on nothing you could do
this in under three years probably
approaching two years
you could be 100 debt free
with moving out yeah yeah you're not
gonna run anything fancy you're gonna
run something that's not fancy
you don't need anything fancy you
suggest
renting then oh definitely you're broke
okay you're 190 000 in debt you don't
need to buy a house
right because i know
at first like of course you have parents
and family everyone's going you know
don't rent don't rent buy so we've
always had like buying in our heads at
least the same people told you to get
190 000 in debt
yeah yeah so i don't think i'm taking
their financial advice anymore they're
not bright
yeah you need to get this mess cleaned
up because if you don't have any
payments at all
you're married
two years and from now three years from
now no payments at all and you're making
135 by then you'll be making more
making 150 000 a year you can save up
and buy a house pretty quick can't you
and crap you're only 23 24 years old
right
yeah correct yeah so i mean we're
talking at 25 26 you start talking about
buying a house and you'll be able to put
down a huge chunk because you're used to
living on nothing
and paying off debt
so my next question is because then i
have about roughly 20 in my savings and
he has roughly 34. oh good this is going
to go even faster then because we're
going to throw all of that at the debt
okay that was my next question and i
know i've just recently actually found
your instagram page and i've watched the
steps um so technically i guess we're at
step two because we could take some of
that and have our small emergency fund
so then you suggest
if you were married you would just list
your debts all of these we've talked
about the hundred and ninety thousand
smallest to largest and you would apply
the seventy 70 000 worth of savings to
the smallest ones until it ran out
okay and got you down to a thousand
bucks now that's all after you get moved
and you know you're going to put up some
deposits and that kind of stuff and
you're going to pay for the marriage
license
are you seeing a theme here i keep
talking about you getting married did
you get that thing i know i hope he's
listening
yeah
i hope he is too because if he's not you
ought to kick him out
i know
i'm gonna tell him you told me so yeah
yeah i mean he needs to start let's man
up here if this is your woman dude let's
call it okay do it let's move forward or
it's time to start acting like adults
not 14 year olds and let's get some
stuff done here you can do it you can do
it you're smart you're smart people
you're you're not dumb y'all make good
money at 23 years old i mean you're
really
you're really bright and you've done
really well but you're making some money
you're making you know you're you're
emotionally
living below your age
because you're in your mama's basement
playing shack up
instead of getting married and going and
being two adults as a married couple
grown people
yes and so i'm trying to push you out of
the nest here for your own good because
that's where you'll prosper
when you guys throw your shoulders back
like two adults and get after this
you're gonna see some huge progress and
lock arms and be the first big
joy of your new marriage is to be able
to clean this mess up and move on i'm
i'm proud of where you're going to be at
25 already i think it's going to be
awesome
and i'm just being pushy to get you
there for you doesn't do me and it
doesn't do anything for me
i want to get you there matter of fact
i'm going to go ahead and give you a
wedding gift uh i want you to go through
financial peace university
uh and i'm going to sign you up for a
year with your new husband uh for ramsey
plus and uh
and uh get them in there and we'll get
this going all right open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five sean is in atlanta georgia hey sean
how are you
hi mr randy how are you better than i
deserve what's your question sir
so i've been listening to you for about
a year and a half now
i've got probably a hundred dollars down
wow following your program my mom has
gotten me started on it so
i'm 26 years old i have two daughters
unfortunately they're both split
families um separate moms
i'm currently living with my
mother i only make about 60
000 a year
as a ford dealership technician
um
i took your advice and got rid of the
big stupid truck that i do not deserve
good and since i got it on a really good
deal i was able to pay off several other
notes that i had awesome um i'm a little
short on time go ahead and ask your
question sean
okay i just
i'm trying to figure out what i need to
do to be getting myself my daughter set
up
i have
very very little invested um i had to
get another vehicle i drive 70 miles a
day i needed something reliable i got
another car
how much do you owe on the car sure
um 19. okay you bought too much car
you're a technician man you work on cars
you know you don't have to have a 19 000
car to have a reliable car
yes sir i didn't know that yeah you just
impulsed again so let's get that one
sold and get down to about a ten
thousand dollar car you just need
something reliable that's not sexy and
get rid of your car notes and then let's
begin to attack these debts uh like you
hear me talking about every day you can
do this you can do this the fact that
you're asking the question means you're
ready to go
uh it means you're ready to do what it's
gonna what it takes to get there so you
hang on we'll also send you a total
money makeover book and you show you
exactly what to do to walk through those
baby steps dude you can do this uh it
sounds like you're ready now
before you were just starting to play
around the edges but now you're ready to
actually execute and get after it and do
what it takes to win
so good job man good job
good show today james and kelly in the
booth i am dave ramsey your host we will
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there is
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you